Texting, sharing photos, instant messaging.
This is how so many of today's kids socialize.
But they can also use these digital tools to threaten, gang up on and cyber bully other kids.
What you may not realize about cyberbullying...
...is that it's not always just one bully and one victim.
Often, many other kids are present too.
Some stand by silently.
Some join in and some may even stand up for the bully.
Experts say that kids standing up for other kids...
...is one of the single most powerful ways to stop cyberbullying.
So how can you help your kids learn to be upstanders?
First, teach respect.
Kids' online communication is often purposely vague.
Your best bet is to teach them how to text, IM and post respectfully and responsibly.
And if they say something inappropriate online,...
...then make sure that they apologize immediately.
Second, encourage empathy.
Ask your kids to put themselves in another person's shoes.
If they can understand what someone else is going through,...
...then they're far less likely to bully another person...
...or to watch quietly as others get bullied.
Finally, tell them to speak up.
Encourage your kids to let an adult know what's actually happening.
If they don't feel comfortable confiding in you,...
...then let them know that they can also talk to a teacher or any other trusted adult.
The bottom line is to never say or never do something online...
...or in a text message that you wouldn't say or do in person.